[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream
139 q and a segment about ready to go
i think it's prime
i was thinking about it the nine is
throwing me some part of me feels like i
feel like we did this
two times ago and why is my computer
pulling up a random spanish app when i'm
trying to do
no saying
yeah no say either
um yeah that's not helpful okay i
um so not helpful
uh
yeah it's a twin prime 137 and 139 our
twin primes next door they're
neighboring primes yeah yeah anyway we
forgot to mention that before yeah
no i didn't forget i just thought
[Music]
i wasn't sure of myself i also wasn't
sure what episode number we were at and
so sure it was all very much live and on
the fly it was yeah and it continues to
be all right so here we are q a 139
second half of a twin prime
and we're gonna start as usual with a
question from our discord uh and
and then we'll go into the questions
that came from you and we'll go for
about an hour
and then we'll stop all right and then
we'll do things that you can't see
right yeah exactly yeah
okay uh discord question this week in
episode 134 q a
got some weeks back remember episode 135
no okay
brett talked about why we should
understand why nazis did what they did
to avoid it happening again
he emphasized that as a jewish human he
is even more interested in it as quote
it always happens to jews
as a jew living in poland and interested
in this part of history i would love to
hear his analysis
why is it the case that it always
happens to jews i think knowing that
might be equally important
yeah i will say
a
this is a very serious research topic
and
stay tuned there will be
important things headed your way that i
think you will be
delighted and fascinated to to encounter
but
as to the question of why this happens
to jews
i think that there is a very basic
problem
where
as economic growth
peters out
there is a go-to strategy for generating
something that feels like growth and it
involves figuring out who can be
safely targeted
in other words if you have a population
and there's
not quite enough resource
for that population
that population will be on edge they
will be aggressive towards each other
and if you can channel that aggression
aggression towards a subpopulation that
is not in a position to defend itself
then you can essentially take their
stuff redistribute it and create phony
growth
so that's just a generic right that
could be true in any context in which
there are subpopulations of some
population you don't have to we don't
you could you could be totally
artificial you could do this in a
college classroom you could figure out
which students are no longer entitled to
speak in class and you could reapportion
the time that those students might have
spoken to other students and create uh
speech growth right what we call in a
hundred gatherers guide to the 21st
century
uh sort of a pseudo frontier
a transfer of resource funds it's a
transfer of resource frontier right and
so the reason that jews face this again
and again
is because
of the odd fact of jews being a
permanent diaspora and so the point is
whenever the culture
that they are
living within
faces a growth crisis
it's um
a always available strategy to go after
jews and
the flip side of that
is that jews have
done what i would not predict if i
didn't know of this population and the
details of it what i would have
predicted would be impossible which is
to persist in spite of that
permanent vulnerability
so i believe jews know an awful lot
about
how to survive
having faced this
particular selective pressure again and
again but that it is
this odd fact of a diaspora population i
mean there just aren't that many jews in
the world and
we are widely distributed and
so anyway it is that
that fact that causes this to be a
recurrent phenomenon i believe there may
be other things but i think that's the
primary one
all right
first question from the q a this week
from darkhorse emissions.com
is there an arms race for lowest
fertility age between boys and girls
is it limited by girl's ability not to
die in childbirth and boy's ability to
fight other men over a fertile woman how
does it correlate with general life
expectancy
um yeah i'm struggling over the term
arms yeah it's not it's not going to be
an arms race um
because
uh
because they're not inherently well it's
not an arms race and they're also
uh not inherently
linked to be symmetrical like there's
there's
uh and we and we see in humans that um
uh that boys and girls have
well different peak fertility moments
when men and women have different peak
fertility moments and uh culturally that
follows in in most cultures in the world
as well
right um
the
a mating system will affect this right
and b
yes this has a dramatic effect on
longevity
even if you
uh correct for hazards
males are shorter lived and they are
more vulnerable and the reason for that
is
because selection the competition
between males for accesses to mates has
driven evolution towards
strength and vigorousness in men which
comes at a cost trade-off wise it cannot
help but come at a cost and so the idea
is if you are ever going to win a
company if you are in a let's say a
politionist society
if you are ever going to win a
competition that is based in
physiological strength and prowess if
you are ever going to win that
competition then it can't be because
your strength and prowess are
distributed evenly over over your
lifespan because right there's a goat
it's going to climb fast and then
decline over time right because
otherwise i'm going to finish this
if you did have great prowess and
uh and
capacity distributed evenly over your
life than somebody who decided well i'm
going to borrow from late life in order
to make myself even stronger in early
life would end up with the mates so the
point antagonistic plyotrophy
non-genetic version it can be genetic it
can be non-genetic it's both but the
point is it drives everything
in the direction of
men
burning hotter and burning out faster i
guess the other the other thing
which may be the most important is
we have the longest childhoods on the
planet for a reason that's not that's
not something that selection is trying
to solve that's not something that we
inherited and now we're moving towards
shorter and shorter childhoods no we
have we have longer childhoods than our
closest relatives which suggests quite
the opposite that there is selection for
for
us to learn how to be human for all of
those years when uh children are not
living independently and for the very
early part of that of course not capable
of living independently
uh now you know depending on the
situation and the culture and all it's
possible that in some in some cultures
an eight-year-old could plausibly live
independently but you know honestly
really not
and uh even if they could
what then are you sacrificing between
the ages of say 8 and 16
when in most places
girls and boys are not becoming parents
you know there are obviously a lot of
exceptions but in general
even even though menses is starting
earlier and earlier in weird countries
where kids are over
over caloried basically and over hormone
from exogenous sources
in general it's more like 13 14 15 in
pre-industrial cultures and peak
fertility isn't for a few years after
that for girls so
really um 17-18
is
when child bearing really begins to
start in earnest for for most women
throughout the world
in in cultures that don't have either
the surplus of calories and
non-intentional exogenous hormonal
influences but also don't have access to
birth control where they can actually
regulate
you know both their sex lives and their
reproductive output so i want to make a
slightly different argument on uh
menses starting earlier and earlier in
girls
there's a influence not only of mating
system but also of
place of phase in history right so when
a population is new in a habitat in
which there's lots of room it can grow
when it has filled that place it reaches
carrying capacity and it becomes stable
the
strategy
deployed by either males or females will
be altered based on whether or not the
objective of the exercise is to produce
as many offspring as possible what you
would want to do if you were in a
position for your population to expand
or if you are trying to produce
successful offspring in a highly
competitive environment where the
environment is full right
so
what i've just said effectively is if
you have too many resources for the
number of people
then a longer reproductive lifespan is a
good idea because the more offspring you
can produce the more likely to survive
into adulthood and
be part of that growing population
therefore
were you to give a population too many
resources we might physiologically
understand ourselves to have just
discovered a brand new frontier and the
race might be on to produce as many
offspring as possible and one way to do
that is to push reproductive age earlier
in women
and so it might be yes we are hormoning
ourselves into confusion but it may also
be that we are responding to a false
signal that we've just discovered a
frontier and that that is moving that
age earlier and earlier to the point of
absurdity
all right
next question is a comment not a
question ranting at gesticulating
struggling not to be sarcastic heather
is my favorite
thank you i think
have you heard the jeffrey sachs
interview with rfk can you comment on it
i know it exists i have not heard it
nope i haven't heard it yet
uh i'll i'll bet it's a bit it's
fascinating but haven't heard it
i've heard that adhd is a holdover from
the faster more agile hunter mindset and
has become maladaptive in a society
built around the slower more constant
farmer mindset thoughts
i think that's the wrong formulation
yeah i would say but the broad idea of
like it's not a it's not a disability
what you know why are you calling it a
disorder is i think is an evolutionary
yeah it's a hyper novelty issue your
truth your you've got an adaptation out
of its natural context and that doesn't
mean that it's malfunctioning it means
it's out of its natural context yeah but
not hunter gatherer versus pharmacist
right right i would say um
we do a lot of dumb things
with children who are you stop there
yeah we certainly do but sorry um
kids are wired to learn right it's
what's good for them
and we deliver
a anachronistic
economically optimized education rather
than something optimized around
enriching the mind and making it more
capable
and it does not surprise it should not
surprise us
that kids are
um
not
captivated by
the often boring frequently misinformed
person at the front of the room quoting
the
deathly dull and almost chronically
uh out-of-step
textbook that we have forgotten to
update with any of the knowledge that
happened after darwin or whatever um you
know so the point is in that context
one might be a bit antsy
and
um
so it's not hunter gatherers versus
farming it's uh outsourcing all of your
children's learning and babysitting to a
school environment that has financial
incentives that don't maximize the
educational potential of the environment
yes and i think you know the problem is
adhd was you know i'm not saying there's
nobody who has an actual disorder there
may well be this may be one of these
things where a real disorder was
enlarged into a bunch of nonsense in
order to prescribe more pills to more
people seems to be the point of the
realm
yeah but
to the extent that lots of people now
fall within some umbrella definition of
some disorder that we claim exists
that definition didn't exist when people
were living a primarily
agrarian existence but if we were able
to impose that definition how many farm
kids have it i would say very few which
argues against the idea that this is
hunting and gathering versus farming and
it's really uh a
hyper novelty
issue
pure and simple yep
i watched darts last week a petite
female player beat a large male player
this is obviously evidence that men have
no advantage over women in sport
did it yep yep well done good job also
in uh
cams
in what isn't cam's a thing
some little
i don't know board game with plastic
round pieces that
did i invent it i mean i don't know i
there's i'm sure there are games that
i've never heard of so i i don't know
about it
so men have an advantage in knowing
about obscure games
one man has an advantage in knowing
about a game that he may have just made
up
i thought
i'm pretty sure i didn't make it up i
may have made up the name
yeah so i was i honestly i was not
trying to troll you but my first
question was how is that spelled because
then i would have some sense of whether
or not i'd ever heard of it but you're
not going to know how i thought you were
saying carom like you know billiards
like the you know the the reflection of
the ball off the bumper but
uh but that's not what you're talking
about
no no
i don't really know what i'm talking
about except that i
uh the playing surface and the
pieces okay yeah i may have totally made
up the name of this
game that once i find cairns
is it cairne is that cool no karen's is
a place it's in australia oh
yeah yeah cairns
it came at least the way i would spell
cairns
doesn't come out so this is going to be
one of these things where i did see an
object and i was probably seven years
old and i asked what it was and somebody
said what it was and maybe i
misunderstood what they said or maybe
they had moved on to the next topic okay
oh wait wait wait wait okay so when i
was like okay maybe he's maybe it's
carom so i'm right about what a caramel
is you know like a collision followed by
a rebound shot in billiards which the
cue balls excuse me the bars um and then
i get a bunch of pictures of toilets
because there's a brand that has carom
in it and then i get
american-made classic family games the
carom company um i think we're getting
close maybe quality made family games
um
[Music]
nope nope i got foosball i got a balance
board skittles oh karam there's a game
called carom there it is wait maybe hold
on it's
i'm doing all your work for you thank
you i appreciate that
first time okay
thank you
for that yeah someone's recording this
that's the game you want to put your
screen up oh i've so do hold on i
because it was freaking out this
connection is weird right you guys know
this
no it's it's coming
okay
there it is okay see the carom
keram yeah i wouldn't have
i would have had an r and it's from the
company called carom so they just made
up this game wait a minute no no no no
no what this is how you play this is
like a all-purpose game all-purpose
board wherein you can play
backgammon or checkers
or
like this is just a board
there it is
it's definitely crocodile that i meant
even though i've never heard that term
but yes it's crocodile that i meant this
is these are the two products tagged
crocodile i'm supply it was surprised
you've never played crocodile
that was you
i don't think it's a real thing i think
this is this these people have made a
game board where and you could play a
bunch of classic games including
checkers and backgammon that is the
object and
crocodile
that that is the object i held all those
years ago and somebody said carom this
object yeah well that board you so you
what what is the analogy there's also
little fake pockets there like like
oh oh like you can
you could play like a little bit of pool
on its own
exactly that's not how you would i don't
know how you would hold a
little tiny pool cue um
that's not really the question
the question is was i making it up and
the answer was no
you weren't making it up but you were
wrong oh both of those things are true
well i wasn't wrong i was i was there's
no game called well there's no game
called cams okay okay and there's no
game called carom either which i got you
there and i found this board but it's a
board on which you can play other
existing games like all right all right
um crocodile okay yeah crocodile but
here's the thing let's let's
let's hypothetically let's go back to
this context in which i was a
seven-year-old child
okay
i pick up the object if i discover that
this company came into existence in 1980
right well it depends if they took over
this game from somebody else it's carom
it's named for the family company it's
never the film fair enough okay so this
is a prediction of this hypothesis but
my guess is i picked up this object
and i said
what is this
somebody said something like carom game
board and i thought
carom
modified game sure that it was a board
for playing the game of carom yeah and
then and you guys totally uninterested
in game playing we're like oh cool but
no thanks decades later i then said to
my lovely wife
that i thought carom
was a game yeah why did it come up
you said caroms harems
well but i think we've re this is rather
like the motorcycle accident i believe
we have actually
reconstructed a plausible explanation of
how i ended up there obviously i was
referring to something
enough for you to search up something
that matches my memory of what the
object looked like well i actually had
the connection google would not have
come up with this if i had put in carom
because it didn't it came up with
karen's australia um so i had to say
well i'm reminded of carom what you know
a thing over in billiard space so i plug
that in and i come up with this there it
is
i'm perfectly happy with that that's my
first reaction was the right one how is
that spelled
it was in this case right because cam
is
well different i mean the answer to how
is it spelled
is obviously how the [ __ ] would i know
but i thought
i would have thought it was
k
a r o m but this is obviously right i
never saw it written i just
heard it said
yeah
k-a-r-k-a-i-r-m doesn't get anything
no well i i think we've done i'm happy
because we have
well you don't you don't think this is
the most likely explanation for the
strange sentence i said to you and then
the blank look that you gave me um
i'm gonna i think we put aside the blank
look part but uh i think the strange
sentence yeah probably yeah good i don't
know how we got there
i don't think we're answering a question
were we
i can't remember how we got there yeah
it must have been somehow though oh no
doubt
as a transhumanist
i invite brett to a more in-depth debate
on the topic in the meantime consider
the state of tech 250 years ago versus
today
and project forward 250 years from now
um
error
what you have said you may well know
better than this but what you have said
suggests a linear extrapolation and you
will notice i have a go-to example for
this
if you have tech we're talking about
change yeah yeah if you look at the
movie or the book 2001 movie's better um
but if you look at that movie
and you look at all of the title they
did this the favor of placing the movie
at a precise moment in time they told us
when this was supposed to be 2001 and
you look at all of the technologies
in this thing a permanent orbiting space
station a permanent
moon base the ability to travel across
the moon by computer a commuter
conveyance uh lab meet
um
video is there lab meet
yeah there's lab meet
now but it wasn't in 2001. i should see
a fly just came in it was so dumb that i
was able to pick it up and throw it away
drunk on isopropyl um but if you look at
all the technologies in that movie
my claim is the only one of them
that was even anywhere on the radar in
2001 was video calls and they were
unusable
right so
what happened how did people as
scientifically literate as
stanley kubrick and more importantly
arthur c clarke arthur c clarke who
correctly
predicted uh
the geostationary satellite this is a
scientifically sophisticated person
however the timing of these predictions
is always very tough and i know this is
part of your well but my point is that
that was there's 2001 is from 1969 1968
68 68. so the point is not that many
decades ahead they were 33 wildly off
right likewise we can say
um you know we have uh
first powered flight 1903
men land on the moon and returned safely
to earth 1969
66 years from first powered flight to
travel to the moon and back manned
travel to the moon and back
okay why aren't we we've slowed rather
haven't we why have we slowed rather and
the point is well there are a couple
reasons maybe people lost enthusiasm
that's what people typically say
a little but that's not it it's the
difference maybe people started
believing in the social construction of
reality
nope too late no that's part of it it's
too late it's part of it it's too late
we stopped making progress on this
puzzle early before that yes but and my
point is this is diminishing returns
telling us you cannot extrapolate
linearly on the steep slope at the face
because you inevitably reach that
plateau yeah and so my my point is
simply
extrapolate forward i'm sure there will
be shocking things um but it might you
might be doing a linear extrapolation
and thinking my goodness imagine where
we'll be given what i've seen in the
last law
imagine where we'll be and the fact is
you just can't do that extrapolation
yeah i will say this is going to sound
like a total non-sequitur and we haven't
talked about this but uh we watched as i
am sure many other people did the first
episode of the game of thrones prequel
uh whatever it's called house of the
dragon or something like that
it's um you know house targaryen is on
the iron throne i think it's takes place
172 years i think it starts i think it
said 172 years before the birth of
daenerys targaryen who um
everyone loves or hates or loves to hate
or something from game of thrones
and
you know i was
who knows jury's still out we'll see
there's only one episode available so
to those of us who aren't in the
industry
but
one of my overwhelming
honestly disappointments with that first
episode was
they appear to be engaging with all of
the same technology as they are engaging
in 172 years later or you know
192 years later however
daenerys is supposed to be you know how
i get
that the game of thrones audience for
whom this is made obviously
wants to see the same level of grandeur
and
the cinematography and all of this but
i didn't see anything missing
well but i'm not sure you would over
that time span over 100 and almost 200
years yeah i mean that's kind of
the point about the extrapolation is
that we have
the
there's a question about what
technologies would show up in
a
narrative like the one in that first
episode right would you see anything
that was um
uh would you see a difference
well how long so i think for instance
there would be true there would have
been a lot of changes
as there were in the actual history of
life of human life on on earth
in the you know middle and
late middle ages
uh in terms of like cooking technology
and heating and irrigation and moving
water around and such and maybe you
wouldn't see those things in this kind
of show but for how long for instance
would
is it jousting is that the what toby
declared the stupidest sport ever is
that what they're doing right um how
long was that which makes for you know
remarkably gory and exciting television
i guess if that's what you're into
um for how long in the actual running of
history that happened was it really the
thing that people did in these big you
know
in
in festivals was it a 200 was it a 200
plus year like that's the dominant thing
that that men do to demonstrate that
they are
important enough to have flowers thrown
at them by women
i don't know i feel like that would have
been a little different
and i have no idea but i i don't find
anything how long a period passed before
before the birth it's 172 years so it's
200-ish years
yeah but 200-ish years and the average
moment in history doesn't involve an
awful lot of change and what we've seen
but we're talking about
i mean
it's obviously it's fantasy based it's
based on a on medieval yeah um europe
right right i mean that's that that's
what it is
and
no i don't you know i don't neither you
and i know a tremendous amount about
about that period um but
things things changed and it looked
exactly the same like the you know the
the clothing the
the buildings the you know the
everything
yeah but things change i think that this
is uh emphasized by our
position in history that's remote for it
from it so that we see all of this
change over a much longer period of time
and we imagine a constant rate of change
but no but i'm i'm not imagining a
constant rate of change i guess i'm
informed in part
maybe the the part of this
that i feel like i'm actually the best
informed about with regard to the rate
of change through
through that period
is from a book that i think i've talked
about here before
that was actually recommended to me by a
student of ours lily called consider the
fork
which is a history of the kitchen
effectively it's a history of culinary
technology uh beginning it's been a
number of years since i've read it but
beginning sort of in that era
and yes there's you know there's more
and more information the closer to the
current moment you get because that's
the nature of history and historical
record keeping
but the number of changes that were
happening behind the scenes that allowed
for other things to happen is remarkable
and one of the messages i took from that
book was
every generation
every generation even in those you know
sometimes hundreds of years that seemed
you know from our vantage point in
history to be like oh you know
grandparents and grandchildren and
great-grandchildren like they all lived
the same kind of life like no they
didn't there were actually advances
constantly happening that are more or
less cryptic to us from our perspective
now and you know maybe you know i so i
suspect that hbo is just being sloppy
because most people don't care about
this um but it's also possible that
these changes would legitimately be
cryptic enough
that they just don't don't show yeah
it's possible yeah well anyway we'll see
maybe it'll be interesting to see if
they do pick up any uh important
differences between uh those two periods
yeah technologically but yeah i haven't
done it yet if it
turns out to be worth watching which
i'm not convinced yet yeah
all right
mike
i don't know about this question my
question is about vitamin c
it seems that humans used to make
vitamin c
why do we stop can we start again is the
goat an actual goat truly the goat when
it comes to vitamin c i don't know about
any of this yeah i don't either um
when you say that humans used to make
vitamin c i'll be very surprised if the
answer that actual humans made vitamin c
if you tell us that our lineage had that
capacity
um and that it has been lost it would
have potentially been lost because
dietarily we were able to source it yeah
although i mean primates one of
one of the most one of
the hypothesis for the radiation of
primates that i find the most compelling
which is i don't know
it doesn't matter the timing um is that
it's it's coa it's synchronous with the
radiation of angiosperms of flowering
plants and that basically primates is a
forgiverous lineage that you know we we
became
so numerous and abundant and then you
know
many tens of millions of years later the
human story is a little bit different
but basically we have forgivery we have
fruit eating
in our history from a long way back
and you know fruit fruit tends to be our
dietary source of vitamin c fruit and
leaves but
if if if that's right if for givery
if suddenly the emergence of lots of
different kinds of fruit helped make
primates radiate and become
relatively dominant in a lot of tropical
forest ecosystems then
what would have been true that would
have made humans
to make vitamin c given that we have a
digestive capacity
to to take in and
make
make good with fruit which is a great
source of vitamin c well i think slight
issue with your claim that we are
a
inherently fruit eating lineage because
to air as human to forgive is divine
all right that was unforgivable but it
is what it is but anyway so here's the
thing about uh frugivores forgive huh
yeah forgive
to eat fruit
typically the adaptation is a much
shortened gut because fruit is so easily
eaten so a i would just say
a frugivore anything yeah you don't need
a spec it's not a specialized you know
leaves
yeah leaves
um meat is intermediate yeah but uh
anyway yeah actually that's
i guess there's changes in dentition yes
changes in sensory you know nose you
know we become less less nose dominant
more visually dominant as primates um
but yeah the gut adaptations are a
simplification rather than an
elaboration and really it all ought to
be a simplification because
um the thing about fruit is it's one of
the very few substances on earth that is
built to be eaten right
right we've still yeah but used to but
you know but
uh
you know fruit all
fruit doesn't simply want to get taken
by anything that finds it
right right it wants to be dispersed by
the appropriate disperser who can do a
good job of like grabbing it and running
away and dispersing it somewhere else as
opposed to eating it in place but the
point is the relationship between the
fruit plant and the intended frugivore
is a collaborative one and so the point
is the fruit is built to be easily
digested to be
highly rewarding to be
pleasant all of the things that are
useful for that particular frugivore
are built in by design because it
enhances the um the value of the
investment that the plant makes
uh in getting its seed distributed
so the question really is and i am not
saying that human beings or our
ancestors
however far back we're good at making
vitamin c i really don't know maybe i
should never but i don't know um
it's quite possible that it is like a
product of a normal physiological
um
process and that
yeah quite possible
but
but the the point would be
you can imagine to the extent that human
beings or our ancestors adopted
forgivery
that the plant might be in a position to
make vitamin c
plentiful and inexpensively
and that the ability to economize on the
production of vitamin c
would have made the fruit valuable and
so you could imagine us losing that
capacity if fruit were reliably
available you could imagine us losing
that capacity because
[Music]
it was
an economically
it was valuable to offs to effectively
outsource the production of vitamin c to
plants yep um
so that all potentially makes sense and
then the answer to your question could
we start making it again is presumably
not not without some sort of
genetic modification well
uh so strangely my brief google search
while you were talking
resulted in this article which zach you
can show if you like
with the title this is in the journal
human gene therapy
restoration of vitamin c synthesis in
transgenic gullo negative negative mice
by helper dependent dinovirus based
expression of goulon no lactone oxidase
so that's a lot of gibberish sounding
stuff
but yeah so it turns out there's
as far as we currently know
there's a there's a relatively simple
toggle gene um that we don't have and
that some other number of mammals don't
have but mostly mammals do
and so we actually it's not that humans
used to and don't anymore it's that
humans like a small number of other
mammals can't and what i haven't found
yet is whether or not it's humans and
indeed all primates which would be
consistent with this
with the frugal expansion
um uh
with the
co-evolution and expansion of flowering
plants and primates hypothesis uh or if
it's sort of scattered throughout
euthyrians yes
now here's the thing though what you
have suggested yes an adino
vectored transgenic
it's got everything doesn't it well hold
on this is from
2008. it's a while ago i think you've
spotted the next vaccine and the
question is from where will come the
mandate
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah
totally i'm sure someone's up to the
challenge uh you wouldn't want to be
deficient in vitamin c because you'll
fill up hospital beds and grandmothers
will die okay so that's a good one yeah
um how dare you
i supplement vitamin c i'm not taking up
a hospital no no you're not what
happened what am i oh i see
okay nope
there we go
how do we distinguish mental illness
derived desire to transform the body
from legitimate desire to match to the
body to perceived self-image
uh
stuff it's not gonna be a clean boundary
i mean
i'm going to do an aside here because i
think it's worthy
think about
how radical an intervention it is in
human psychology
to have
mirrors
right in a world without mirrors even a
world in which you know yeah there are
ponds
but a pond only gives you such a good
look right it's a it's a at best it's
still kind of it doesn't hold still it's
not a perfect rendering yeah right
so imagine living in a world
in which
your understanding of how you look is
actually
just simply a response to how people
interact with you based on how you
actually look right so
you know i mean it's not the same as
growing up without a mirror but i
specifically wrote about the sum
actually my first book from the
experience of being
a nosy manga being island off the coast
of madagascar for many months at a time
with no mirror right and um
having gone to town for something and
having discovered that i had some fungal
thing there were white spots creeping up
my neck onto my face and i asked my
field assistant at the time why didn't
you tell me it's like what was i going
to do about it what were you going to do
about it
like well i don't know but maybe it
would have been nice to know yeah but
but anyway it was fascinating
fascinating to live um without any
ability to reflect
on what it was that you looked like for
months at a time right but it's still
not
it's not the same as having thousands
right have never having seen yourself
right and early your mirrors remember
also weren't very good right early
mirrors were polished metal which is not
you know not much better than the pond
right what actually kicks loose a mirror
that gives you a photorealistic
impression of what you look like is the
ability to polish glass that you can get
so smooth that when you silver it what
you get is an actual faithful rendering
so anyway my point is
i actually think we'd be way the hell
better off
if we didn't have ourselves to gaze at
in a oddly
you know alice in wonderland reversed
fashion
and then to obsess over these things if
you were interdependent enough on your
kin to tell you what you did need to
know and to not tell you the stuff that
you're probably better off not knowing
and you know imagine the temporary fixes
that are possible are you gonna wanna
you know but if
if there's something you can't do
anything about like do you need to know
you've got a uh a lemur on it
thank you
i mean actually let's just follow this
through yeah okay
imagine you know you look like something
because everybody else does and you
don't know what you look like wait wait
i didn't understand that sentence
everybody looks like
everybody looks like a person you look
like some person that you'll never see
you can see all the others but you can't
see you know you look like a person yeah
okay all right
so imagine that what you did
was
even not even consciously but you just
modified the way you interacted so that
the way people looked back at you was
like they were gazing on somebody who
was
you know
nice to interact with
you modified your behavior so that
others people's reflection of you
uh hold on
that that is a world in which
what you are getting is something like
an honest reflection because if people
are repelled by you and want to turn
away and not uh continue to interact
that's a negative message and then if
you change something and people are more
inclined to interact with you so the
point is it encourages good behavior it
encourages
inner beauty at some level because it's
not always the best looking people who
are the most fun to you know talk to in
fact often not right so
um so the point is
the mirror and its ability to let you
obsess about your own looks without any
other feedback it's sort of the opposite
weird thing about what we say about the
person at the front of the room
uh who is in a position to misinform you
about reality right in this case you're
you're well the mirror kind of let the
mirror allows you to focus only on the
external indicators on the superficial
stuff yeah yeah now this this is true
although it yeah that
it's going to be different for men and
women sure it's going to be quite
different and yes um
truly you know staggeringly gorgeous men
do have people just stop on their tracks
and look at them but that's a
much rarer phenomenon it's a much rare
phenomenon and they're
not all of gay
uh but
uh
you know it's interesting
actually i i've been reading and this is
from well into the age of mirrors but
i've been reading a bunch of fiction
from uh the late 19th and early 20th
century of late
and
the description of
how females how women look and of female
beauty and such
strikes me as dated you know strikes me
as not not the way that i would be
describing such things now of course but
it also seems to be a match for the kind
of thing you're talking about where you
know there there are some
individuals in these in these novels
who just leave a trail of awe behind
them regardless of what how they behave
because they are that and women because
they are that stunningly gorgeous
um but almost everyone else
you know has to work you know yes you
know in this in this milieu there's a
lot of frippery and you know and working
hard to make the external look more like
you're expected to look
uh but you also
there was also
aside from the very very rare truly
extraordinarily gorgeous being
everyone is sort of vying for like well
what else do i have like what else am i
bringing
and in you know in the age of
tick tock for lack of a you know a
better scapegoat here uh it is
you know increasingly people i mean
maybe not increasingly but it's really
easy to just default to like well what
enhancements can i put on the outside
right right like
artificially you know augmenting stuff
rather than
i want to draw a distinction between
um
beautiful
and attractive
right beautiful is a commentary
primarily
on
um phenotype
well no i'm gonna back that up it is a
commentary on uh features
however
there it is certainly true i speak for
myself but i'm sure i speak for just
about anybody who thinks about it
there is the person who if you stop to
think about it is not
beautiful but is very attractive and in
some cases it's even true that somebody
who may
have characteristics that you would
think count against them beauty wise
is very at home with themselves yeah and
confident and funny or whatever and you
think that's very this person is
attractive and it's almost like yeah
they're just not superficial right they
actually have they have depth yeah and
yeah if you think if you if you look at
a picture
of them perhaps you're like oh i mean
that's a little bang the eyes a little
squinty like it wasn't quite like not
beautiful and this is quite different
from the from the distinction between
beautiful and hot right
that we've made multiple times and
and elsewhere here and here but um
but yeah you can't you know but so one
of the things about modernity
is the ever
increasing number of ways that you can
change your features your actual
features right right the and you know
this this is quite analogous to the
trans activist argument as opposed to
the trans argument like morphological
freedom well if i if if i wanna
you know have a penis formulated from
the flesh of my arm then i should be
able to do that
no actually not sure you should be able
to do that
but if i want to
increase the cup size of my breasts by
three sizes and uh make my eyes bigger
and add a horn out the back then i
should be able to do that because some
people find that really attractive like
okay i guess we have the technology but
you know
maybe develop a skill right like
maybe do something that's actually going
to last and that will make you
a more you know interesting valuable and
frankly happier as well happier and
attractive that's that's really the
thing is
the
ability
to obsess on your own features
has not been a win i mean i have
you know i think mirrors are probably
the worst invention we've ever had
because of the psychological distortion
i'm not sure about i'm not sure if i do
write down it's possible i'm forgetting
something but i think the problem is we
do have a kind of
uh
a hellscape of self-obsession yeah and
that is in part the result of the fact
that you can sit and look in the mirror
and imagine what could be better or
whatever and not get on with your life
and not learn that skill that makes you
more attractive to people
whatever it is and so
i think the thing is
we're never gonna know
how much harm is downstream of the
ability to just simply i mean
i guess the point is you don't realize
that it is a optical miracle to be able
to walk up to something that looks like
a window and see yourself as if you're
equal distance the other side of a piece
of glass yeah that is a
non-normal experience and it is
psychologically
uh profound
and i mean again to go back to the many
months that i spent uh on aussie manga
beat with no mirror and you know the the
next long field season that i was there
which is with you having lived through
this the first time the first five month
field season i didn't take a mirror and
i didn't tell you to yeah and you know
we again it was i think just four months
that time but you know we're without
mirrors now then we had each other and
so you know if i had
the lemur or whatever
yes i got the euro played as glued to my
head but um
it was
incredible it was incredibly freeing
it's like yeah i'm i'm here to do
research
um it doesn't matter
like
you know i i can still smell myself and
still see the part like it's not about
showing off in any way to anyone else
that's not what we're doing here and
not ever running into a mirror by
accident intentionally
uh was was amazing and actually i
remember
actually that after that first long
field season when you weren't there with
me my parents were living in london at
the time and i went through london first
and spent um a week or so with them and
walking past store windows and just
catching my reflection constantly i was
like
how do people live like this right this
is insane like also all the people like
all the strangers my mother will
remember that i was kind of freaking out
like i can't i don't know how to deal
with all of these people and by the way
where are the geckos
but the constant catching your own
reflections story windows i found
particularly
alarming yeah after months without being
able to see myself at all i guess i'm
this is this is it is
you don't understand how distorting this
is and you know it's the story even you
know you have the culture shock of you
happen to not be with the mirror and
then you return to civilization and even
the reflections and the windows are
jarring
and that's having grown up with mirrors
everywhere right right and the point is
you don't realize how profound an
influence this is on everything that
everybody's got these things yeah right
that everybody has multiple interactions
with these things a day right that
at the very least you would want to ask
the question well was that a win was
that net positive right or did it have
serious consequences for us
um that
weren't so good totally
uh
okay
what are how long have we been going
zach
[Music]
all right we got a lot more questions
here i'll get to as many as i can
um
sorry
do you know the morbius movie
drafting the bat biologist to explain
everything wrong with the morbius movie
i'm just going to try to get through
some that we can get through quickly i
don't know the morbius movie the biggest
flaw with it is that it's too obscure
okay i need to warn you guys
the game of podiatry is afoot
[Music]
are cultures incorporating alcohol
reaping a benefit and or managing a
poison
mmm
good one yeah that's a good one
um are there are there any cultures that
don't have out i mean there are
obviously there are cultures that outlaw
it they forbid it but it's still there
and it still gets used yeah uh but are
there i mean no one hasn't discovered
alcohol because alcohol happens
alcohol well okay alcohol might not
happen in the arctic
do the do the inuit
uh have alcohol pre-contact a good
question for european contact
my instinct is yes but it's it's
like how
what's
what's brewing
i don't want to say something dumb but
you could yeah imagine
getting it from you know fermented
seaweed or something yeah um yeah
but all right let's back this off a
little bit from humans for a second
you will
often hear
tales um
where people are
often arguing that you know getting high
is normal right and their point is well
animals have been discovered to do this
animals have been found you know eating
fermented fruit and falling over you
know all this right now i always point
out in response to these now do when
cows do that they go out people dipping
they're big tempers though oh you know
as animals go right um my dad used to
get drunk and go at cow tipping when he
was a teenage boy in iowa is that right
yeah i'm a little surprised it had been
invented but i guess i guess it would go
way back well i don't i think it
happened at least once
at least once yeah all right
anyway um
the okay so you happen upon a troop of
monkeys drunk on fermented fruit and
fermented fruit is not uncommon yes
sponges this is why
aside from the arctic where
ferment happens alcohol happens right
one of my favorite neotropical trees
spondeus big bat tree um
the fruits are delicious they come off
the tree but often if they've been off
the tree even a little while you taste
the alcohol and yeah and you get dry
like it drops like you you know when
you're walking under a respondus tree
just post um peak fruit production
because you're stepping on all these
little it's like little round orange
fruits is that right yeah yeah um and
they're just all over the place and it
smells it smells first like ripe ripe
fruit and then it begins to smell like
alcohol like yeah but anyway you happen
upon a bunch of monkeys eating spondeeus
and drunk here's what you don't know
first of all almost all creatures are
starving or don't have enough food
almost all the time right because
populations grow to use up whatever food
is available and so they're
they if they're not resource stressed
they grow until they are so almost all
populations are resource dressed
fermented fruit has caloric value it
both has the
value that hasn't yet been destroyed by
the alcohol-producing
yeasts and it has the value now stored
in the alcohol right
so what you don't know is whether the
monkeys
chose to get drunk whether the or they
were just having a meal yeah did they
accept getting drunk because it was
better than not having the food yep and
is it possible in fact highly likely
that the monkeys have evolved a
reduced annoyance at drunkenness and
possibly even a delight in it because
you would have to have such a thing you
know it's basically an acquired taste
um but you don't know that what drove it
was hey we want to get drunk rather than
uh hey we want to have a meal and
there's all this spondy is here and it
would be a shame if it went to waste
right so
um
anyway
now impose this on humans right do
humans like to get drunk yes they do but
how did this happen well you've got a
bunch of um
ephemeral foods
that can be stabilized
by converting a lot of their calories
into alcohol which population after
population has done especially as you
get into uh habitats where food is very
scarce for months at a time so you know
bread is hard to make unless you can
keep the
uh the flour dry but beer is stable
so anyway there's lots of interaction
between the shelf life is rather
different between the two absolutely
absolutely so you know but bread is
lighter so for you know for three day
trips you want to take a lot of bread
for storage in place you prefer beer yes
now to get through the winter beer is
better to to do a day trip bread is
better this becomes tricky when you're
going into space because bread is
lighter so you think of bread's to go
too but it takes up
all this room so does beer
yes
but
[Music]
this is why no one has hired me to help
them get into space to help with the
food logistics in space specifically
yeah you're not going you're not you
should not be at the head of that hiring
queue
i mean only briefly until the interview
ah
yes i don't think you should get to the
interview you don't i no
all right food logistics in space no but
people who do those interviews they need
levity also so sure sure
um someone says hi zach
but they spelled it with an h and then
they say muscle memory foils me again hi
zach
so i'm getting three more questions
hello he says
how could the majority of scientists and
doctors been so wrong regarding kovid
and its treatment should we ever trust
them again
um
two points
should we ever trust them again as a
complex question because there's you
know on the one hand
no and on the other hand what choice do
we have so the question is how can we
resurrect medicine so this never happens
again and they can be trusted how can we
resurrect trustworthiness in medicine
that's the question yes
um
how could this have happened
i think that's a very interesting
story and one that needs to be explored
and we're not going to do it fully here
but i do think
there
this episode in history has revealed
some things that we knew that needed
greater uh
insight you know mass formation and all
is not a new concept but we've now
understood something about how it
functions that i think certainly many of
us did not know and maybe nobody did
um but
in some sense you had people
uh you know there aren't very many uh
professions with an oath
medicine has an oath
right
we had
doctors by the hundreds of thousands
violate this oath
how did they do that did they know they
were violating the oath do they violate
a
deeper obligation to themselves and lie
to themselves so they wouldn't violate
their professional oath and if so what
is happening now right at what point
how many of them who engaged in
self-deception in order to get through
it are still self-deceived right and at
what point is your self-deception so
willful and egregious that it doesn't
even count as self-deception because you
know that you're running from a truth
that's right in front of you and i don't
know how we deal with this but i will
say
the one piece of actual wisdom i have on
this front is
yes
the vast
number of doctors who saw things
understood that there was more to this
puzzle understood that those of us who
were concerned about it were not crazy
and didn't say anything
have
in they have
engaged in an egregious breach of trust
they did so under duress
right this did not happen in a vacuum
this happened with threats to
livelihood and ability to earn it
happened with threats to reputation
there will always be duress well there
will always be duress and i expect
people to
to stand up under that kind of pressure
because
what's what's at stake when it's doctors
who
buckle is life
right
but
you don't want to rush to the conclusion
that
these people are effectively no longer
doctors the question is how can we
confront what happened so that we can
rebuild medicine without having to start
from scratch
yeah i guess
i mean
i have a lot of questions
and one of the questions
that comes to mind here is
uh
given
how much evidence there is
now for a variety of forms of early
treatment
in the scientific literature
in empirical experience by many doctors
in the u.s
and in the formal protocols being
adopted by many other countries
how
do american doctors
[Music]
continue to explain to themselves
justify say to patients
if you get covered the only avenue open
to you is yet another pharmaceutical
it's called paxlovin
how do they do that how how
so so the only way to protect yourself
is one of our
vaccines
and the only way to deal with it once
you're sick which you will get sick even
if you get the vaccine it's not like it
helps with that
is paxlovid
i i
i don't see it i can't i can't i cannot
get
i i i i just don't know how you could
possibly if you are a practicing
doctor
who is actually recommending courses of
action to patients
and you are not telling them
to
get in the sun
and
consider laying in
especially in the winter and taking
regularly
d and c and magnesium and zinc
and having a supply of melatonin on hand
and
still super dicey in the us
got us demonetized
but for [ __ ] sake
hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin yep
are
good treatment yep and they're good
early treatment
and almost everyone else in the world
knows this
what is going on
yeah and that's half the story too
because at the same time that they are
recommending uh
the dangerous
novel pharmaceutical and failing to
recommend the things that actually work
they are also continuing to recommend
vaccination when increasingly doctors
have the evidence in front of them of
people who have maladies that they
shouldn't have yeah and you know okay
also the doctors who are doing these
recommendations
you have a patient in front of you
that patient has some number of
comorbidities
some of which they can take control of
with changes to diet and lifestyle
that's what you encourage them to do
you do not pretend that you fix your
health with pills and you keep on doing
all the crap things that you are doing
all of us do things we shouldn't do and
which impair our health all of us make
decisions that are bad sometimes this is
not about blaming the obese or blaming
the people with diabetes or with kidney
failure or anything
but
many of these conditions
have in them an element which can be
improved with changes that the
individual can take with regard to their
behavior and the choices they make
they should be doing that and their
doctor should be telling them that they
should be doing that yeah
not simply writing a script
in fact um it is dereliction of duty it
is dereliction of duty and this goes way
before coven yes right the fact is
preventive medicine is not a new concept
it is obviously the right thing to be uh
advocating and a system yes that is
hell-bent on
waiting for you to get sick diagnosing
your sickness quickly and throwing a
pill at you without regard for its uh
side effects
um that's obviously not a system
interested in your health and this is
precisely what um you know the
allopathic medicine the mds are much
more likely to do the like i'll just
write you a script and make deal with
your symptoms maybe not maybe i'll see
you for another 10 minutes and six
months maybe not
but you know we started the show our new
sponsor this this outfit wisdom health
that is helping connect
functional medicine doctors with
patients
that's most of those that's going to be
naturopaths um and i can say
now having dealt extensively pre-code
you know forget covered for the moment
if you can um
that the allopathic medicine industry
is largely very confused on questions of
evolution and diagnosis
and you're far more likely to find
people who are willing to and interested
in thinking and in actually laying hands
on your body and figuring out what is
going on with you over an osteopath and
naturopath territory much more likely
yep i agree yeah
okay
um
two more
and
sorry we won't get to all of these
which vaccines are necessary safe and
effective during pregnancy and first
years
i would not take any vaccines during
pregnancy and
as a long-term advocate of vaccines
someone who was in the business of
explaining to my students why they
needed x number of vaccines before they
traveled with me to panama to ecuador
i would i never would have thought that
it was a good idea to take any vaccines
during pregnancy it's the the the embryo
fetus baby
uh is just far too fragile at that point
to to risk that there's there's got to
be a better way
first years is a different question
well but but it's a continuum of of risk
so what what heather and i did with our
own kids
when
you know
we were just normal parents facing
recommendations
normal parents facing recommendations
but we were evolutionary biologists who
had thought about who you know who had
done darwinian medicine stuff yeah right
and we said
to the pediatrician um
we'll do everything that is strongly
recommended
as delayed as possible
and the idea was the more of your
development that has happened before
something bad happens to you the less of
it will just be disrupted now that is
not the approach i would take now but i
would say that that is the floor of a
reasonable approach
i am now much more alarmed that some of
these vaccines are completely
unnecessary and carry a hazard
and others may be still necessary some
of them may be necessary but badly
formulated
and you know
i don't know who's going to clip this
and what they're going to do with it but
the real point is
i still think
the technology behind vaccines is among
the most important discoveries uh
medically speaking that humans have ever
made however
i do not trust these for-profit goliaths
that construct them that then test them
and tell us how safe and effective they
are we now know just how dangerous that
is
and that puts us in a bad predicament
it's the same predicament with the pills
right you don't know
how much risk you are taking when you
engage these things and you should do so
as little as possible and so in the case
of vaccines we've just gotten used to
the idea that you go to your doctor they
tell you what you need and you take it
and it's not beneficial and
now i think we have to look at them and
say
which ones are actually net beneficial
and how good is your evidence i mean i
guess
one of the outcomes of
coven over the last two and a half years
is
you know i used to actively assess
before going to the tropics okay what
are the cdc recommendations for this
country in this place and you know how
how recently did i have for instance the
rabies vaccine and do i need a booster i
need to have my tighter check you know
cholera vaccine isn't very good oh
typhoid comes in two formulations like
there's a whole lot of this analysis
and there was some amount of choice and
some amount of like actually no you just
need yellow fever if you want to go to
the amazon like oh i want to go to the
amazon i'm going to get the yellow fever
vaccine right
um
i didn't
so i had some sort of like a gut
idea of like how the recommendations
were put in place for the tropical
vaccines that aren't in the country
where you're in and which of these
things were negotiable and which weren't
and why and i thought about that a lot i
never i never considered for the last
two and a half years
who decides the schedule for childhood
vaccinations it just hadn't hadn't come
up right and so now
given how
criminally awful the cdc has been
over the last two and a half years in
terms of its recommendations and given
that the cdc is actively involved in the
vaccine recommendations for uh for
tropical countries for travel
i have to wonder if they're involved in
setting the schedule for childhood
vaccinations well then let's take a
careful look shall we
and if it's not them who is it the
american associate academy of
pediatricians well they've made some
stupid decisions lately like every one
of these organizations is compromised at
best and
it shouldn't be
incumbent upon citizens to do all of the
research for every single decision that
they make
but increasingly over in medical space
it looks like no one is watching out for
us yeah no the whole point is you're not
supposed to have to research the stuff
yourself and you're not supposed to have
a background to be able to evaluate it
and even if you do have that background
you don't know
what you don't know where the bodies are
buried in these trials that's what we
now know right so
this is absurd but the degree to which
the recommended vaccine schedule for
children has
positively exploded right with vaccines
is
it raises a question in and of itself
even if each one of these vaccines
it's gone up
as
the rate of childhood infectious
diseases was already going down and it
hasn't
it hasn't gone up proportional to new
decreases in childhood disease right
right
um
the
fact that not only do you have all of
these vaccines about which we know not
enough and we don't know how reliable
what we think we know actually is but
there is also an obvious biological
question about whether or not there is a
[Music]
harm to the number of vaccinations one
gets
in other words
not only the effect of the individual
vaccines but what is their net effect
and if there was in total right if it
was true
that you are over programming your
immune system for pathogens that it will
likely never see
then the questions will you would want
to prioritize which of the you know if i
get seven shots at building an immunity
that i should actually want and
shots okay
seven opportunities to build an immunity
but if you know above that number i'm
actually degrading my capacity to fight
off pathogens generally can we talk
about prioritizing right and the
question is if that were true i'm not
saying it is true it's a hypothesis but
if it were true do we actually think
that the pharmaceutical industry would
have allowed that investigation or would
it have persuaded us not to do that
investigation because what it right now
has is a very sweet deal where it comes
up with a vaccine it says the vaccine is
safe and the government starts
recommending it through your doctor
right and the point is you know
this is especially when you're talking
about babies and small children and new
parents and new parents going
the most important thing in the world is
that my baby is safe right the most
important thing in the world is that i
do what is recommended and oh you tell
me if i don't then if something happens
to my baby that's my fault that's my
fault right and the person is just
saying that like how how freaking
diabolical right especially when it's
your doctor right yeah you're trying to
be a good parent and your doctor says
well you really should have these
it's like well doctor how much do you
actually know
right and like oh how how
how about i mean we actually had we were
we were lucky uh we had a very good
pediatrician
um
now you know we what we said you've
already said what we said but we said um
we want to know
all of the you know what
which vaccinations are highly
recommended
and uh which ones maybe not so much
and how late can we push them so the
child each of the each of the babies has
as long as possible to exist without
having um
having this thing on board
and
that conversation was possible back in
2004 through 2010 whatever right
uh but it you know that that
conversation is not an anti-vaxxer
conversation right in any way in any in
any way
but it would it would easily be taken as
such in today's environment and worse
right given what we now know
we would have a different conversation
right we might well research each of
these vaccines individually i think we
would certainly
yes we would do exactly what i always
did for the tropical vaccines yeah and
yes and so what what happens when you
come into your pediatrician's office and
you say
doctor actually i've looked into those
they are
uh
net negative yes to these no to these
that's where we are these three yes
you know then the question is now put
vaccines aside now you've said something
that your doctor takes as
anti-scientific and uh anti-public
health right what kind of child care
kind of medical care does your child get
from then on and so really the idea
i mean look well this is you know
another reason to find yourself an
osteopath or naturopath
right but remember when pharmaceutical
ads came on television and they had
people dressed up as doctors and they
would say things like well i'm not a
doctor but i play one on tv you know
that sort of thing but the idea is yes i
do
um a
doctor
has a special authority in part because
they've taken a [ __ ] oath
right they've gone to medical school and
they've taken a [ __ ] oath and that
doesn't mean that they're not liars but
it reduces the likelihood now what
happens when pharma captures your doctor
and starts speaking through them turning
them into a sock puppet and your doctor
hasn't done the research on the
individual
uh vaccination and they say oh it's been
tested it's safe and we really but they
did get that nice weekend in arizona to
play golf on you know on pfizer's
account or whatever well i don't know i
know that happens with pills i don't
know if that happens yeah no i i don't i
don't know i don't know vaccines but
anyway that's the idea uh look you know
getting people it advertising is evil
product placement is evil
getting your doctor to product place
yeah in real life your doctor while
playing your doctor coming into the room
and looking at a chart and recommending
i'm a doctor and i don't play one on tv
but i'm here to sell you something that
was sold to me by the guys that just
bought me a nice vacation yeah
anyway so
here we are here we are one more
question i know that was a long answer
and we're probably way over and my
computer has since died but
here we go
and no we didn't give you any specific
answers because we have not researched
the particular childhood vaccine
schedule at this point
final question for today what are you
hopeful for and worried about regarding
the ongoing psychedelic renaissance
oh interesting right um
yeah let's put it this way
i think i speak for both of us
um we are huge fans of the potential
in
various psychedelics perhaps not all of
them but certain psychedelics certainly
provide
the opportunity for people who are
well structured psychologically to
accept the opportunity to
retool i'm saying
they're not for everybody
i think the
fact is the population is poorly
structured to accept these things
because the population is too interested
in being entertained and thrills and
stuff like that and so it doesn't treat
things like this with the kind of
seriousness that one should and i will
say what i always say i'm not saying you
shouldn't have fun but fun should be
downstream of this was productive and
that's why it feels great right rather
than it feels great without productivity
right so
um
narratives are great entertainment is
bad as an a la carte concept
so anyway my point is there's lots of
potential here i'm concerned that we
will take something marvelous and
precious and once again squander its
value and exploit it in stupid ways and
all of that
there is
also a therapeutic avenue in which
one would get professional guidance in
this right where a substance would come
along with the proper preparation and
the guidance i think there's tremendous
potential in that assuming that the
people doing it know what they're doing
and
i am concerned about and i know we've
encountered discussions where
companies are trying to patent and limit
the access to certain compounds because
their claim is that they have the method
to dispense this in which it's most
useful and i'm very concerned about
these things being captured by a
for-profit mechanism
that will limit people's access to do
what the ancients have done with them
for thousands of years
yes good um
there is one more question that came in
that is on a topic that we talked about
maybe coming up and it's possible you
want to do as you it's possible you want
to do this now it's possible you want to
wait till next week it's possible when
you do a separate video i'm going to
read it and you can decide okay
brett please comment on the sam harris
meltdown and walk back you have been
gracious to him beyond understanding but
his behavior is now a very large
elephant in the idw room
well i mean people will
if you've been paying attention you will
know
uh that sam had
a what many understood and i understand
as an um
incredibly revealing
discussion on
uh trigonometry the trigger pod and he
said some things that were very
provocative and were widely reported on
and
um and i certainly thought about saying
some things and i have not done so
so far
um
i do think something needs
to be said because
a
the uh
the answers he gave were revealing about
topics
that were at least not covered as far as
i saw in the primary podcast
sam has said some
sam who is a friend
has said some really extreme things
about about heather and me
and
they are things that i think have not um
they have
not worn well
they have not aged well they look
terrible and ridiculous in retrospect
and i personally am waiting for sam to
notice that
um and i think when he does notice that
he will do the right thing and that we
are entitled to have him do the right
thing um far better than us pointing out
the uh contradictions and
what the test of time has has said about
what um sam alleged
but in any case
short of that i do think that there's
something that needs to be said and i
feel entitled to do it because
because
the attacks that sam made on us were
quite pointed and quite specific and
setting the record straight is a
reasonable thing to do and it's not it's
not mean-spirited and it's not
anti-collaborative he said things very
publicly and responding publicly makes
makes perfect sense so anyway i will
likely have more to say later unless sam
um corrects the record in the meantime
but that's that and that's more or less
where we are
all right
we will be back
uh next week
and
same time same place
we encourage you to join us tomorrow on
my patreon at 11 a.m pacific for a
private q a and next saturday before the
live stream uh at brett's patreon for a
private small small group conversation
and and next sunday as well but not
tomorrow
and in the meantime
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside and achieve
greatness
[Music]
[Music]
you